[Inaudible].
An asteroid racist toward earth. It's big, it's fast.
And it's about to do a lot of damage,
but we're not just going to sit around and wait for the end of days,
we're going to fight back
What would happen if we nuked to an astroid,
would it save humanity or make things worse?
How does a nuclear blast in space compared to a blast on earth
and would our nukes even be strong enough to destroy it?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we nuked an astroid
in the year 2,175,
the asteroid Benu will pass by earth.
And there's a one in 2,700 chance that it will hit us.
If those sound like good odds to you think again,
Benu is taller than the empire state building.
And it's 15 times heavier than the great pyramid of Giza.
And if it hit the earth,
it would release as much energy as 23 SAR Bombus,
which is the largest hydrogen bomb ever exploded.
Do you still like those odds? I'd like them a little more.
If we had a contingency plan for NASA,
that's the hyper velocity asteroid mitigation mission for emergency response,
also known as hammer and just like its name suggests the
plan is to Ram into an incoming asteroid or to detonate a nuke that will
send it off course, but will it be enough?
And what sort of repercussions could we expect?
The sooner we discover an asteroid heading our way, the safer we'll be.
For example, if we detected an incoming asteroid a year in advance,
we'd only have to change its course by a few centimeters to keep it from hitting
earth to do this, we could detonate a nuclear bomb,
a few hundred meters away from the asteroid causing it to change its course and
move away from earth. And if that didn't work,
we could just crash into the asteroid with the most powerful bomb we've got.
But if anything were to malfunction before the bomb reached the asteroid,
the resulting consequences might even be worse than the asteroid hitting earth.
But once the nuke was in space,
the world's population would be relatively safe with no atmosphere out
there only vacuum the blast would disappear,
but the radiation would be much stronger while people on earth would be
safe.
Anyone in any nearby spaceships would be risking their lives in
the interest of preventing as many casualties as possible.
This would have to be an automated mission and assuming that nothing goes
wrong and there isn't some kind of AI mutiny,
we could very well succeed in pushing an astroid off course,
as long as it wasn't too big,
a bigger asteroid would require bolder tactics, such as dark,
dark stands for double asteroid redirection test
NASA plans to slam into an asteroid in 2022 to change its orbit,
the impact would be equal to three tons of TNT.
This mission could result in the first ever manmade meteorite shower.
And if it works,
it will serve as a blueprint of how we could respond to asteroid threats in the
future. Of course, when it comes to destroying Benu,
the bomb will use will be at least a million times stronger than what dark would
be packing. And yes,
we've got nukes that are that powerful.
The only thing we'd have to look out for after blowing up a giant asteroid is
space debris.
The debris could severely damage our satellites and endanger any astronauts
aboard the international space station.
And if any larger chunks of the asteroid found their way down to earth,
they could create craters up to 20 times their size
On the bright side, if the nuke exploded close enough to earth,
the radiation that admits would be distorted by our planet's magnetic field,
which would probably be the prettiest light show ever.
Or if you don't want to wait for a doomsday scenario,
you could just take a trip up North to see the Northern lights.
It's crazy to think that nuking asteroids is a potential survival plan
for humanity, but considering it's us against well,
pretty much anything in the infinite void of space we have to make do with what
we have.
Have.
You ever thought about how you would survive a solar storm?
Find out what we do by checking out our news.
How to survive.